una recta pasa a través de los
siguientes puntos y la ecuación de la
recta está escrita de la forma y es
igual a mx más b cuál es la ecuación de
la recta ok y tenemos justo aquí la
tabla dándonos los puntos por los cuales
pasa esta recta si te das cuenta esta es
la forma pendiente ordenada al origen y
bueno en esta ocasión creo que podemos
visualizar algo de una manera muy
sencilla si tú te das cuenta creo que
podemos sacar ven con mucha facilidad
porque ve es la intersección con el eje
de las 10 y aquí lo tenemos de una
manera muy sencilla porque cuando
nosotros interceptamos al eje de leyes
entonces x debe de valer 0 y en este
caso aquí en este punto se ve claramente
que es lo que pasa cuando x vale cero
cuando x vale cero interceptamos al eje
de las 10 en el valor de ocho tercios
por lo tanto ya no puedo escribir aquí
al menos ya sé que me vale
ocho tercios ahora falta encontrar la
pendiente y bueno como no puedo escribir
aquí voy a pasar a mi libreta de notas
para encontrar la pendiente de esta
recta que tenemos aquí así que ok aquí
están mis notas y ya puedo trabajar aquí
la pendiente que nosotros necesitamos
encontrar al menos ya sé cuánto vale
bien entonces vamos a escribir de nuevo
esta ecuación que tengo aquí y para esto
déjeme cambiar a éste pincel y voy a
poner justo esto ye yé es igual a m x +
even b vale 8 tercios es el dato que me
dan justo aquí por lo tanto voy a
sustituir lo aquí más ocho tercios ahora
date cuenta que podríamos encontrar la
pendiente como el cambio entre el cambio
en x sin embargo voy a utilizar otro de
estos puntos para sustituirlo aquí en
esta recta y así encontrar la pendiente
recuerda que todos estos puntos pasan
por
esta recta y por lo tanto me voy a fijar
en este de aquí en este de aquí esto
quiere decir que cuando x vale 110 vale
2 voy a sustituir justo aquí cuando
llévale 2 entonces x vale 1 m x 1
ok más 8 tercios y voy a conservar estos
8 tercios ok y ahora voy a despejar la
pendiente si te das cuenta m por 1s m
entonces esto me va a quedar a 22 es
igual a m por 1 lo voy a poner con este
color que es m
ok más 8 tercios más 8 tercios ok y como
yo quiero despejar a la pendiente para
saber su valor entonces voy a restar
ocho tercios de ambos lados de esta
ecuación para que se cancelen estos ocho
tercios así que aquí voy a quitar ocho
tercios ok y aquí también voy a quitar
ocho tercios lo voy a poner así
ocho tercios más dos de tal manera que
estos dos se van y del lado derecho
solamente me queda la pendiente m es
igual a dos menos ocho tercios pero si
escribimos al dos en tercios me quedan
seis tercios seis tercios menos ocho
tercios
es lo mismo que menos dos
de lujo ya tengo la pendiente la
pendiente vale menos dos tercios y
también ya tengo la intersección con el
eje slayers que es otro tercios
por lo tanto regresamos a la página y
vamos a poner aquí que la pendiente vale
menos dos tercios ok vamos a poner aquí
que mi pendiente vale menos dos a
tercios
ok es hora de comprobar la respuesta y
perfecto estamos bien vamos a hacer otro
ejercicio más para seguir trabajando con
este tipo de problemas
ok perfecto tengo ahora esta tarde aquí
y bueno en este caso también le dan de
una manera sencilla cuánto vale sin
embargo qué te parece si trabajamos esta
misma tabla
pero ahora vamos a pensar que ese día si
no superamos el valor de b y bueno para
resolverlo entonces déjenme sacar por
acá a mi libreta de notas ok tenemos
este vamos a quitarlo
y quitar este porque el problema
anterior vamos a quitar lo íbamos a
poner ahora el nuevo problema ok y dice
una recta pasa a través ok es lo mismo
cuál es la ecuación de la recta muy bien
entonces me voy a tomar los dos puntos
más sencillos para poder sacar la
pendiente recuerda que con dos puntos es
más que necesario para encontrar la
ecuación de una recta en este caso como
me dan un montón de puntos me dan más de
dos puntos puedo elegir cuál de ellos me
va a servir mejor y déjenme mover un
poco esto cuál de ellos me va a servir
mejor para encontrar mi pendiente y se
me ocurre tomarme este de aquí ok y este
de aquí entonces vamos a fijarnos cuanto
cambie con respecto a cuanto cambie en x
y bueno si nos fijamos en x pasamos de
menos 2 hasta el 0 y por lo tanto
nuestro cambio en x nuestro cambio en x
va a ser igual a aumentamos 2 aumentamos
2 de este punto a este punto ahora si
nos fijamos en pasamos de 0
y por lo tanto el cambio in game el
cambio y bueno pues aumentamos también 2
y por lo tanto del tate y también es 2 y
ahora sí ya puedo decir que mi pendiente
mi pendiente es exactamente lo mismo que
el cambio el james con respecto al
cambio en x ok y esto es exactamente lo
mismo que a 2 este 2 de aquí y déjame
ponerlo con este color 2
entre este otro 2 entre 2 por lo tanto
ya sé que mi pendiente vale 12 entre 21
y bueno en el dado caso de que todo lo
que resuelve de la forma habitual tú
podrás decir bueno este 72 menos 120 es
2 entre x 2 - x 10 menos -2 es 2 y 2
entre 2 otra vez me da 1 ok ya tenemos
la pendiente de esta recta y entonces
solamente falta encontrar el valor de b
y bueno ya que tenemos la pendiente la
podemos sustituir en esta ecuación y
entonces me quedaría que james es igual
a m
pero m
de 11 x x x ok más be ok y es igual a mx
más b ahora lo que necesitamos saber es
el valor debe y pasa cada vez bueno lo
podría ser muy fácil con este punto pero
qué te parece si utilizo otro distinto y
se me ocurre utilizar a déjame poner
esto por acá se me ocurre utilizar este
de aquí ok voy a utilizar este de aquí
que dice que cuando x es 310 vale 5
cuando llegué vale 5 ok entonces x vale
ok más b y de aquí queremos despejar
bien y por lo tanto vamos a obtener que
ve es igual a 5 - 3 ok lo cual es pues
espera que este signo de igual lo cual
es 2 de lujo b vale 2 que es justo lo
que teníamos aquí cuando x vale 0
interceptamos al eje de leyes y ok ya
tenemos que la pendiente vale 1 a b vale
2 y entonces vamos a regresar a que la
página para escribir nuestra
puestas la pendiente la pendiente valía
1 ok de balde 2 y es hora de comprobar
la respuesta ahí de lujo estamos viendo